one of the mantras we have heard ad
nauseum since the beginning of the covet
situation
has been that we need to follow the
science this phrase is repeated over and
over by politicians by experts and by
celebrities
let's end the politics and follow the
science
this phrase must be expressed with a
certain level of condescension
implying strongly that your ideological
or political enemy
is not following the science and if they
did
follow the science then they would
naturally agree with your political
position
will people listen to scientists
we've heard certain political parties
smugly even call themselves the party of
science
now we could argue all day long over who
is actually following the science and
people do pointing fingers at each other
and going down the dreadful line of
click bait headlines citing
some new study which suggests how their
position
is the one following the science but to
do that
is already to miss the force for the
trees because it is
actually simply and dare i say
technically impossible
to simply follow the science
[Music]
this is jonathan pedro welcome to the
symbolic world
[Music]
the question is far more important than
just surrounding the current covet
situation
it's rather the sign of the general
blind materialism which rules the common
discourse
we're wowed by the scientific priestly
cast
we only need to look at the type of
reverence the media placed around dr
fauci in the united states but like i
said despite
our officials constantly repeating this
mantra
it is impossible to just follow science
at least not
at the outset when science is doing what
it's supposed to
it's an accurate and quantifiable
description of phenomena at a certain
level of reality
and so because phenomena happen in a
predictable pattern
then once you've described the phenomena
accurately enough
it can be possible to produce the same
phenomena
with similar conditions so think of the
scientific process
as producing something like a recipe
book once you've identified something
relevant let's say
making a pound cake then the recipe book
will tell you what the stuff
what stuff the cake is made of so if you
follow a set process
using similar quantities you know with
certain raw materials eggs flour etc
and a certain amount of time then you
should be able to reliably produce the
phenomena which
will be recognized will which will have
the recognized qualities of a pound cake
so notice i said if you follow a set and
a set process
which of course seems to suggest that
you can in fact follow science
but this is exactly where lies the
problem and the blind spot which has
become so common
you can only follow the science once you
have identified what it is you care
about
what it is you want to do and especially
what is your hierarchy of priorities
within a certain context science cannot
tell you what is important
so let's say you decide you want to kill
as many people as
efficiently as possible well then you
can follow the science
to find the best procedure and tools to
do so if you want to reproduce a nuclear
explosion make people addicted to your
product create an army of robots then
science can possibly help provide a map
to accomplish these measurable goals but
science has no tools whatsoever
for telling you what you should do what
goals you should be aiming for
and science also cannot tell you what is
the reasonable amount of resources you
should spend on a certain goal
or what else you need to sacrifice to
accomplish your goal
so let's say you want to make your pound
cake but you can only get eggs by
driving two hours from your house
well science has no way of telling you
if that is a reasonable thing to do
or if you want that pound cake enough to
sacrifice that time
and energy to still make it maybe you do
and this blindness has been the source
of one of the biggest
political clashes since the end of world
war ii
following the science has provided the
means you know of a
of material excess of comfort and a
throwaway culture
and now other branches of science we
environmental science is telling us
to follow the science you know to save
the environment from the results of this
other
branch of science who developed their
industrial thrust by following the
science
and so science is a tool and neither of
these opposing narratives neither the
reason for the development of industrial
civilization
or the reason for the green reduction of
energy consumptions are scientific in
themselves
both paths both mentalities
both follow the science but they do so
to their desired goal
so this whole question has reached
almost absurd levels with the covet
situation
we're constantly told to follow the
signs that
you know this or that political decision
or
mandate is not in fact political but is
mandated by science at best this is the
naive proposition of people who are
unaware of their own frame unaware of
what motivates their action
but at worst it is a new form of
moralizing which wants to pretend that
its moral stances
are as self-evident and as provable as
two plus two
equals four the goal is sometimes stated
at first we had a goal we were told that
we needed to
prevent the medical system from being
overwhelmed but then the goal post moved
invisibly to we need to
stop all people from dying at all costs
and finally
the goal post became we need to stop
this disease from being spread to
anybody
at all so despite moving the goal post
authorities continue to use the same
message follow the science
while pretending that the goal is
continually continually obvious
it it's just taken for granted and just
plainly there in the science itself
of course if you had followed my channel
you have bumped into this problem over
and over
it's the problem that that i had in my
discussion with brett weinstein
where science was posited as the top of
the hierarchy of meaning
it's the blind spot in my discussion
with rationality rules
where moral arguments were made as if
their ultimate purpose were evident
while simultaneously being incapable of
framing of naming or even
seeing that purpose before invoking this
or that
example or this or that consequence all
of these conversations are in a
different way than we usually mean it
they are blinded by science honestly
thinking they're objective
though blind to their presuppositions
thinking they are objective and
scientific
they take their unseen presuppositions
as self-evident truths
which people which all good people
people who have good intentions should
be able to see
and so those of us who question this or
that moral position
can find ourselves in dangerous
situations because if one takes their
point of view as self-evident
this inevitably means that those who do
not share this perfect perspective
are doing so out of ill will or with
purposeful
and utilitarian denial of science
that's why we always hear a note of
contempt
every time a political figure or public
figure
says follow the science or when they
suggest
that their political opponents refuse to
follow the science
accusing someone of not following
science is akin
to accusing them of breaking a divine
command
science is of course objective
non-ideological until so to not
to follow science is to go against
reality itself
it's a sin properly speaking for those
who think like this of course all the
while the inquisitor
is hiding or maybe even unaware of the
true purpose
of his actions that is why i say there
is imminent danger
right now as for the reality of
safety versus danger of saving lives
versus providing opportunity
normal societies have always had to find
ways
to balance these extremes it's not easy
of course but this is an inevitable
discussion that we should be able to
have
without those who want to have the
discussion being accused
as being science deniers or being
insensitive and evil
if the goal of human society was only to
save lives
we will not go rafting or mountain
climbing or even
get on the highway we know that
intuitively but despite that we're
suddenly paralyzed
by this strange illusion that safety in
protecting our bodies
is the only value that matters of course
it would be absurd to say that it does
not
matter of course it matters we should
care for the physical wellness of those
around us
but it cannot be our only guiding value
safety cannot be accomplished at the
expense of
every other value which constitute the
human experience
value like community exchange adventure
risk taking and especially worship
every time you get into a car you risk
your life
and every moment you are in a car you
could die in a few seconds
and this is in no way under your control
you're also at the mercy of other
drivers
in the united states for example the
rate of death per car is about 12.4 per
10 000.
but there are also four million people
who are seriously injured by car crashes
road crashes are in fact the leading
cause of death in people between
1 and 54 years old now
we could reduce the death and injury
rate of car crashes very easily
we could simply stop all private cars
from going on the road
done or we could reduce the speed on the
highway at 20 miles per hour
i mean i bet that would break down the
car the car death
toll and an injury to nearly zero
it would work but we're not going to do
it so why aren't we going to do it
i mean why wouldn't we do it am i saying
that getting
to my hair appointment or to some you
know to go to the mall
is more important than people dying
see we we intuitively understand that in
order to live our lives we incur
risks of dying of course car crashes and
infectious diseases are not
the same and we certainly need to care
for the weak and the elderly but my
point is rather
to feature our willingness to accept the
constant risk of dying
at any second every day and intuitively
knowing that safety cannot
become the only value which drives our
society
and we must be very wary of those who
refuse to even have
the discussion insisting that the very
discussion is immoral
because it doesn't follow the science
we have to be more aware of what a human
being is and not
not let that go to the side in a society
that is built only on one single value
a value of safety or security
a human person is more complex has other
values other purposes
and some are actually more important
than our safety
i hope you enjoyed this discussion on
the symbolic world
as you might have noticed i am in a new
space i am back in my home since the
flood in 2019
but you can also notice that i am not
yet set up
i'm really struggling to set up my
office the stores are all closed we're
on lockdown
and the stores are also out of
everything i can can't even find
a desk the right size for the office and
so i'm kind of floating around trying to
get everything installed
and trying to get everything right but
very soon
things will be better you notice the
camera is better
the sound will also be better the
lighting will be better and so i'm
really excited to see what 2021 is going
to offer us
in terms of insanity and hopefully i'll
be able to uh
to comment on it as best i can and so i
want to thank everybody for your support
as you know
everything i'm doing here is thanks to
your support
and so if you're interested in
supporting the podcast these videos
go to the symbolicworld.com support
you'll find ways to support it there
you can also buy some of my designs
different designs that i've made
on teespring and so thanks everybody and
i'll talk to you very soon